banlieue sud-ouest de kiev à quelques
kilomètres des positions russes angelina
crainte une attaque imminente depuis des
jours elle s'active pour organiser la
résistance avec ses voisins et son mari
qui a déjà pris les armes
on a mis notre fils de 5 ans à l'abri
car deux missiles sont tombés à 200
mètres d'ici
on est des civils de la défense
territoriale on n'est pas préparé à se
battre contre des chars
combattra les troupes au sol en
attendant le combat ils ramassent les
éclats d'obus tombés ces derniers jours
regardez ce sont les cadeaux qu'ils nous
envoient du ciel ce sont ces imbéciles
de russes qui tuent les civils
angelina et sa voisine prépare chaque
jour des repas pour les militaires qui
protègent le quartier elle leur livre
l'après-midi sur les checkpoint 80 % des
résidents sont partis ils lui ont laissé
les clés les provisions et de l'argent
angelina nous emmène au sous sol là où
quelques-uns de ses amis dorment la nuit
un abri antibombes de fortune où elle ne
veut pas rester
la cave n'est pas si sûr si des missiles
vous rappeler notre immeuble gagne ça
peut devenir un tombeau pour
le quartier était prisé par les jeunes
familles qui acheter un premier logement
ici
on pouvait acheter de l'eau des
bonbonnes d'eau potable et là c'est une
porte qui menait à l'école maternelle il
y avait beaucoup de rires et de cris
juste à côté c'était la cafétéria qui a
été transformé en armurerie
26 kalach
il n'y en a pas pour tout le monde
et là c'est mon arme de sniper infuse
ici c'était le centre de tourisme de la
résidence et du village aujourd'hui
s'est transformé en infirmerie en
centres de premiers secours là avec un
brancard il ya tout
les réserves de médicaments qui sont ici
et ils sont prêts avec un médecin et une
infirmière de cette résidence à prendre
en charge tant les civils que les
militaires c'est une véritable petite
base arrière qui se trouve ici